Well,
certainly not having any choice,
having your entire life dictated by
others.
You know,
like none of us would choose.
No matter where we are in the world,
would choose to,
you know,
become a member of Orwell's 1984 world.
But how much choice is really the
question when we know that some choice
makes you better off than no choice.
Now do we get better off if we go from a
lot of choice versus a few choices?
And there I think the answer is much,
much,
much more complicated.
If you truly have expertise and
expertise can be,
say a chess master who's really mastered
something,
or I'm an artist or a musician of some
sort,
you know,
if you give a jazz musician I once the
jazz musician learns all the
fundamentals,
they can keep track of a lot of choices
in an instant.
A chess master can keep track of more
choices than the number of stars in the
galaxy within an instant.
But these are people that have truly
learned and mastered the choices that
they have and how to deal with those
choices are a very,
very long period of training.
So essentially what they're really doing
is ruling out all the irrelevant choices
and only zeroing in on the most
relevant,
useful choices at the moment.
So most of the time when we are
confronted by more,
rather than a few choices,
we're often novices.
And so we don't really know how to
differentiate these various options.
We also don't always know what we want.
And in those cases,
it can actually make us worse off
because it's actually easier to figure
out what you want and to figure out how
options differ.
If you have about a handful of them,
then if you have a hundred of them.